[Music]
on the tarmac at aludaid air base in
qatar a c-17 opens its doors to a new
life
a three-hour journey that's taken days
of struggle
the aircraft packed with tales of fear
and hope
for one young man this evacuation flight
is a first daunting experience of flying
for the air crew they'll soon be off to
do it all again
this is a huge humanitarian undertaking
and the urgent nature of it
means it remains very fluid
there's no cap on how many flights like
this the qataris will send into
cardboard this week when they leave here
they don't know how many people they're
bringing back
it's simply as many as possible
for those left behind the window for
evacuating is closing fast
it's not clear how many flights are left
and the taliban have stopped people
traveling to the airport
one afghan security guard who worked for
g4s protecting the british embassy in
kabul until last year has lost all hope
of getting out
he told us the taliban is actively
looking for him they came to my father's
house and they had a room by room search
and they were looking for me for my
documents but they did not find anything
but luckily they got nothing and they
left here they abandoned us they are
leaving us behind g4s say they are
working with the uk government to
support a safe outcome for their
employees in afghanistan
this man who holds an australian
passport with relatives in the uk
was beaten on his way to try and get an
evacuation flight
it happened to me
and for the millions who aren't leaving
life is getting desperate
food prices are rising and people can't
access cash to buy it anywhere
since the taliban took control foreign
aid has been frozen
the world food programme has spoken to
sky news and warned they could run out
of funding as soon as next month
you can have unprecedented famine in
afghanistan
unprecedented famine
if
we don't receive the funds we need if
there's not an economic recovery plan
sooner than later because we already
know out of 40 million people 14 million
of them
are marching towards starvation
qatar is already mediating between the
taliban and afghan government officials
about what happens next with talks
underway on who will take over running
kabul airport
they're also a key player in the
humanitarian crisis
accommodation built for qatar's world
cup is now housing refugees
the person at the heart of this effort
is the country's deputy foreign minister
we didn't expect
this number of
babies kids pregnant women
and we're trying to cope with the
situation
everyone was talking about a timeline
that would last for weeks or months
but then overnight everyone was
surprised that
you know what happened has happened and
we need to deal with the situation
and with remaining evacuations now
numbered
international efforts must focus on
helping the people left behind
sally lockwood sky news doha